[Musique]
vieux mixco
de la capitale du Guatemala le jour où
comme c'est excité
[Musique]
Maya, notre identité maya, nous pensons que
les morts s'ils ne se reposent pas
l'endroit où ils ne devraient jamais être
ils se reposeront ou alors ils le seront
je cherche en permanence du repos et je
Nous ne nous reposerons jamais non plus dans le vivant
Ils ne se reposent pas s'ils ne sont pas morts dans le
l'endroit où tu devrais être tu sais que je
Je cherche ma dépouille mortelle
maman, je cherche des défis mortels de ma part
parrainage fraternel de la dépouille mortelle
Victor va mal et aussi les restes
les mortels de mon père et mon père a été brûlé
une ambassade et il s'avère qu'elle n'a pas
grave Que s'est-il passé là où ils l'ont emmené
ce qui s'est passé avec lui, alors qu'est-ce que je fais avec
mes morts
dépression
[Musique]
les chevaux
mais c'est à part, ce n'est pas le sien parce que
tu sais que je suis mon cousin, non, ce n'est plus le cas
de l'autre famille, seulement celle qui est
saisi
Donnez-nous aujourd'hui notre pain quotidien
pardonne aussi nos offenses
on pardonne à ceux qui nous offensent, non
succombons à la tentation et délivrons-nous
du mal Amen Dieu te sauve Marie pleine
Tu es de Grâce, le Seigneur est avec toi
Tu es bénie entre toutes les femmes
et béni soit le fruit de tes entrailles
Jésus Sainte Marie
bienvenue bienvenue frères Dieu
Soyez bénis, que Dieu vous accompagne dans votre
voyage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mexicaine
[Musique]
Musique
difficile
[Musique]
Regarde comment est Victoria, il n'y a pas de vie
et c'est dommage que Victoria ne le fasse pas
Victoria parce que c'est le nom
Victoire parce que c'était victorieux, ce sont des gens
qu'il serait encouragé à entrer et que cette fois
le pays n'était pas en conflit à ce moment-là
les gens ont été encouragés parce qu'ils voulaient
reconnaissez votre pays
et de nombreuses institutions ont parlé de oui
Victoria peut développer ou un
bien la population et il y aura
beaucoup de choses mais celle-là non non non non non regarde
comment va Victoria
De quel pays venez vous?
[Musique]
il
et voici cette clinique
et où étaient les médecins du
docteur du monde Alors quand ils
Ils ont pris leur retraite et cela a été abandonné
et il n'y a personne qui puisse prendre soin de lui dans ce domaine
l'époque où ils étaient
dessert quotidiennement les voisins proches et
Ça vient toujours ici, il y a des médicaments et
maintenant il est parti
23 septembre 1993
Margarita García dimanche
enfant malnutri
Il est venu à la consultation dans l'après-midi avec 41 5
de fièvre
vomissements difficultés respiratoires
Il est décédé à 7h30 alors qu'il se rendait
plage
Andrés Ramírez Jiménez est né le 16 janvier
à partir de 1993
est décédé aujourd'hui
consultant clinique samedi 25
Décembre
gastro-entérite le médecin qui a rendu visite à votre
la maison aujourd'hui a été rejetée par le
père, il n'avait aucune confiance en
des médicaments mais ils lui ont donné des plantes
médicinal
des livres ont été perdus, des vidéos, il y a des vidéos
aussi à l'intérieur
qu'il y avait un ranchón et qu'il pourrissait parce que
puisqu'il n'y avait pas d'entretien, pas quand
Pensez-vous qu'en tant qu'éducateur dans le
possibilités qui seraient ici
un espace de lecture ouvert
profiter de l'ombre dès le départ
salle de participation communautaire où
exposer où projeter des films x
mettre les travaux des étudiants mais pour
c'est ce dont tu as besoin, les gens ici, tu as besoin de toi
avoir
une ressource également économique Quand on
penser aux espaces en zone urbaine
que tu n'as pas grand chose et ici tout
cet espace perdu
les organisations membres de la
mouvement 6 des enfants consacrent ceci
centre pour les garçons et les filles de Victoria
Le 20 janvier, à l'occasion du sixième anniversaire de
l'approbation de la convention du
droits de l'enfant des Nations Unies
l'aide ne devrait pas être un cadeau d'en haut
mais plutôt une aide entre pairs visant à
auto-assistance où tout le monde
celui que nous revenons dans la victoire 20
Les assemblées de janvier ont eu lieu
où les commissions permanentes avaient
organiser des assemblées pour former
les structures au sein de la communauté étaient
une très belle organisation c'est quelque chose
positif de quoi je parle
Hormis les commissions permanentes
ces coordinateurs généraux qui
ils ont appelé, il y avait ces coordinateurs
Développement communautaire que ceux qui
un groupe de personnes devait capturer tous les
un soutien financier qui vient des autres
pays et toutes les organisations qui ont atteint
offrir le soutien dont ils ont dû se présenter
avec ce comité pour dire ce que leur
idée et quel est votre système de travail
pour que ce comité dise s'il reçoit
votre soutien ou dites non, nous ne recevons pas votre soutien
tout le soutien international qui est
reçus d'autres pays d'ONG qui
Ils sont arrivés sur place et ont reçu un soutien selon
un accord qu'ils ont signé entre les
secteurs et a réalisé 50% de
tout le soutien international dans
l'aspect financier doit être de 50%
pour la guérilla et 50% pour la
développement communautaire, vous n'êtes pas
j'exagère Non, je n'exagère pas
C'en est un parce que nous avions
participation directe à ce comité
et c'était réel, ce que je dis est réel
Ce n'est pas un mensonge mais c'est vraiment le
50% qui restaient pour la communauté
Il était utilisé pour la communauté mais
ils sont allés entre les mains des gens qui
ils dirigeaient ce comité
comme deux ans d'un an plus tard, nous
nous devions obtenir cette copie d'un
projeter un projet dont je ne me souviens pas
de quel pays s'agit-il, c'est un projet qui
demandé est un million de quetzales qui
demandé pour réparation
réparation des routes de Victoria
le 20 janvier à une municipalité de
chiisex près de Cobán
mais rien n'a vraiment été fait, c'était un
rapport vide
nous l'avons découvert il a été découvert ce ne sont pas des choses
mensonge l'argent est arrivé il a été reçu mais
le projet n'a pas été réalisé
Non seulement cela, d'autres projets sont arrivés
problème de puissance du toit
minima
dans les outils en grains de base
La quantité est arrivée et puis
il semble qu'il ait été distribué dans le
communauté mais plus rien n'était distribué
Puis nous avons réalisé qu'ici
oui il y a des choses étranges et on le découvre plus tard
Quelle était la politique, la politique
de la guérilla était que le peuple
revenu, il ne doit pas avoir de bonnes maisons
ne doit pas avoir d'alimentation électrique ne doit pas
avoir de bonnes rues, de bonnes routes
Parce que si les gens veulent vivre
confort tu auras une bonne maison tu auras
avoir cette énergie électrique va avoir
une bonne route aura tout
alors ils ne penseront pas à la guerre
il vaut mieux que la guérilla soit suivie par les gens
Vivre comme eux, à quoi ça sert ?
intention de demander plus de soutien
international et que ce soutien vienne
un peu au peuple et à la majorité pour
la guerre si ces soutiens qui sont arrivés
la victoire le 20 janvier aurait été
investi dans la victoire le 20 janvier
en ce moment, nous verrions un grand
ville
et ce qu'on a vu, c'est que ces gens
La personne responsable de ce comité s'est retrouvée avec
Ils ont mis l'argent à la banque à son nom
d'eux et puis ils ont fait quoi
ils pourraient faire avec l'argent mais ça
l'argent est constitué de dons internationaux de
Les ONG, en peu de temps, nous avons vu que
qu'ils ont commencé à acheter leurs voitures
ils ont commencé à avoir des maisons dans d'autres dans un autre
les départements ont commencé à avoir des affaires
dans un autre département disons le
dirigeants
Dès lors le
conflit la contradiction entre
Victoire le 20 janvier ils se partagèrent un
groupe qui a soutenu l'idée de
guérilla, un autre groupe Non, ici, nous ne voulons pas
Une idéologie est celle qui défend le
guérilla, autre que ça, nous marchons
marchons seuls, pas s'il y a du soutien de
la guérilla est la bienvenue mais quoi
faire s'il y a le soutien de l'armée
bienvenue dans tout ce que tu fais
J'ai eu des expériences avec la guérilla
et les contradictions où j'ai été accusé
de la mort et c'est ce que je te dis
dire pour que les autres le remarquent
compte Quelle est la situation mais j'espère
que les gens l'utilisent pour le bien de
une ville qui a beaucoup souffert
Victor
et objet
tu étais au combat et
Bien sûr, j'ai participé à plusieurs combats
Monaco
J'étais dans d'autres combats dans les baies
sur la piste d'atterrissage de Barillas
J'étais là où il est sorti aujourd'hui, j'ai vu
mourir compagnons aussi dans le corozo
Ferme El Corozo sur le front Polisario
Je suis sur le front du Polisario ici à
La Chine a très peu de temps qu'est-ce que c'était
c'est arrivé ici à ce moment-là
c'est qu'entre une division c'est un piège
de l'armée féminine parce que c'était un
piège militaire qu'il y avait beaucoup
confiance et puis c'était pour les projets
et aussi une partie de Warner parce que
Il y a un groupe de compagnons qui était un
travaux des commissions permanentes
qui s'est infiltré avec l'ennemi
puis ils sont venus, ils ont mis cette idée ici
puis c'était pour le piston c'était pour un autre
truc
C'était une trahison envers nous, pour ainsi dire.
parce que la brûlure c'est ça et les publicités
C'est de l'urne, hein, politiquement ils le sont
gérer le travail politiquement, mais
Donc il y a des choses clandestines qu'ils font
mais ils reçoivent des conseils de l'extérieur Non mais
A cet âge on dit que parce que le
l'argent et tout. Ils étaient de purs chrétiens.
On ferait mieux de sortir et de faire quoi
propre et ici se trouvait la base centrale du
Ils viennent diviser les gens, c'est tout
nous sommes là, ça ne marche pas pour eux
Ils sont corrompus, a-t-il commencé, c’est un plan.
une campagne contre
l'insurrection doit être comprise de cette façon et je
Je le dis parce que tu peux voir le mouvement
une catastrophe est très regrettable car
J'avais beaucoup de choses, le camion était perdu.
Le minibus, les deux, le bétail, tout et le
totalement logement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Nous espérons que nous avancerons
[Musique]
ici dans ce monde
personne ne vient composer
mais au contraire il s'agit de
Décomposez cela ici est un exemple dans
Victoire du 20 janvier
les étrangers sont venus
Merci pour certains qui sont venus faire
quelque chose de bien, quelque chose et d'autres
ils sont venus vers nous
s'écarter parce qu'ici il y avait
problème ici à Victoria le 20 janvier
Écoute, eh bien, là où j'ai eu tous ces
conséquences
là où c'est écrit, il n'y a rien qui
ils viennent directement pour donner
[Musique]
tout est livré avec des conditions
où il y a de l'argent corrompt un indice et
C'est triste de voir toutes ces maisons qui
ils les ont rendus vides tu réalises
En clair, un investissement mort
congrégation
[Musique]
dimensions
Cette maison est la maison d'une religieuse
Ils sont venus nous accompagner à notre arrivée
à leur retour, ils furent ensuite
plusieurs fois ici avec nous
Alors, quand l'heure de son
Je suis revenu d'eux et ils sont partis maintenant
Ils ont laissé leurs maisons abandonnées
onces
quand l'arrivée des gens a été générée
qui était absent ou déraciné
à un moment donné avec le RCP, les gens qui
tous ces gens étaient dans la guérilla
Il est venu se concentrer et a commencé à recevoir
soutenir mais seulement recevoir recevoir
créé ce que nous appelons le
Paternalisme des ONG
Puis je leur ai dit qu'iscan était
avec des mains comme ça attendant la manne
est tombé du ciel et à aucun moment
Ils ont reçu des ressources productives
vraiment qu'ils ont produit leur
éléments de satisfaction dans différents
niveaux Nous avons un groupe ici
hétérogène de plus de dix ethnies
de différentes régions du pays et
différentes circonstances de votre arrivée
sortir et revenir car ils sont différents
Nous n'en avons pratiquement pas quatre
rapatriés
du Mexique, ceux du CPR, qui est le
réinsérés qui étaient de la guérilla et
ceux qui sont arrivés migrants avant un
perspective d'un nouveau territoire
il y en a pratiquement quatre et à part le vin
puis le groupe de marchands et tout
C'est parce qu'il y avait de l'argent, eh bien, parce que
l'argent a été manipulé ici à la suite de
les dons et tout
C'est très agréable de te voir avec Los
Les noix de coco, ces noix de coco le prennent dans le
retour Maintenant, nous allons le prendre
où nous allons voir se trouve un
un endroit pur dans la jungle, il n'y a pas
ensuite
c'est pourquoi nous voulons les apporter
graines
[Musique]
Isabel l'Antonia l'Isabel est à l'intérieur
il n'a rien
[Musique]
nous ne sommes pas coupables
dévotion nous voulons le
la commission continue et poursuit ses travaux
mais je ne voulais pas et c'est là qu'ils ont commencé
accuse-nous chacun de nous
Nous m'avons transmis, ils ont commencé à me dire
que Miguel Vargas dit qu'il en est un
de ceux qui s'organisent C'est le
Celui qui a fait le plus est celui qui a le plus lutté pour faire le
division parce que l'armée était
le conseiller
et il offrait sept têtes de
bétail à chaque famille et cinq ou cinq
mille quetzales d'argent
tous les gens sont tombés sur moi
alors ce qu'ils m'ont fait
Ils ont accusé le chef du
guérilla qui me tue
[Musique]
Il y a beaucoup d’enfants, hein, pas seulement nous.
de ceux qui sont ici sont
disant tout de suite que j'espère maintenant
nous sommes grands, nous ne venons pas avec
tu es ce que tu as dit, il y en a beaucoup
ils voulaient quand ils grandiront, dit-il
que là-bas ils vont aller parce que là-bas ils vont aller
faciliter l'étude des
les uns aux autres un moment, pas alors
c'est pourquoi en ce moment ils sont désolés
d'autres sont allés comme chaman
il y en a plusieurs, ils ont quitté Mayaland en quatrième position
ville de Los Angeles, nous avons tous été arrosés
mes filles, nous ne sommes plus ensemble seules en ce moment
La famille 150 est restée ici, oui.
que ceux qui ont n'ont pas de terre
terre Eh bien, si c'étaient ces terres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
éducation
Voici le marché, toute cette partie où
nous voyons que le magasin était un marché
petit marché il y avait des magasins comme celui-ci
donc là-haut c'était une maison
social, il y avait une clinique et là
les écoles étaient là où elles sont
maintenant, il est neuf heures
Le matin, un hélicoptère passe d'ici
Il a survolé le marché et je suis allé acheter
quelque chose de l'eau à boire arrive dans le
stocker dans ce qui vient dans le magasin
Je demandais le produit pas pour
J'ai dû consommer quand j'ai réalisé
qu'ici au milieu de la piste
L'armée était là, ils arrivaient tous
rangée
et ils montèrent et les gens
ils ont commencé à diriger tout le monde
côtés, ils ont couru là-bas, ils ont couru et
alors qu'ai-je fait, j'ai dû courir
courir pour voir où aller parce que déjà
Je savais que l'armée devait tuer
les gens quand j'ai vu ça déjà le premier
un soldat était déjà derrière moi comme un
corde d'environ 20 mètres de long, qu'est-ce qui allait arriver
Peut-être qu'ils ne m'ont pas tiré dessus parce que
Il est arrivé très lourd, la charge l'apporte très
lourd et là le fusil l'enlève
je descends déjà là-bas dans un comme un
cinq cordes là-bas, j'ai trébuché sur un
le coffre et quand j'ai trébuché, je suis tombé sur le ventre
et puis quand je suis tombé, je ne suis plus
J'ai pu me lever parce que celui-là
Un cauchemar est arrivé. Le cauchemar était que
ici, les genoux sont devenus faibles et je ne pouvais pas
me lever même si je devais faire le
Je ne pouvais faire aucun effort, ça m'a pris du temps
jeté, je ne pouvais plus. Puis jusqu'à ce que
J'ai dû faire l'effort, je me suis levé et
Je me suis enfui et les gens ont crié et
les tirs là-bas viennent de l'armée, non
Un jour, il a tué des gens, mais
ils étaient sur le point
huit jours huit jours Alors le
d'abord les hommes se séparèrent
les femmes, les enfants et les personnes âgées et
c'est les filles à part puis le
les hommes étaient punis ici, il y avait un
cave ici avant
Ils ont été punis, torturés. Puis
de loin on pouvait entendre le
Disons les cris et et des soldats et
qu'ils ont dit où sont leurs parents
Où est la guérilla Où est la
simple patron alors d'après ce qu'ils ont dit
ils ont coupé les oreilles une à une ils ont coupé
les langues une à une l'ont tué
les hommes et ensuite ils l'ont emporté
brouette à tirer une à une
eh bien et les enfants sont comme les enfants ne le sont pas
Ils n'avaient rien à dire et les anciens
Ils les ont mis dans une maison où il y avait
une école rustique ici qui venait de
bois, le plafond était tout en bois
Puis ils ont allumé le gaz et le
Ils ont brûlé vifs et les femmes ont été
les filles ont été violées une à une selon
On dit que les filles sont les
Les derniers que je connais sont morts, combien
des gens sont morts plus de 400 personnes
entre hommes, enfants, personnes âgées et personnes âgées
aussi
un après-midi, je travaillais et je
J'ai commencé à m'asseoir là
J'ai commencé à m'asseoir là, puis j'ai
J'observais ainsi uniquement l'endroit où
J'avais passé à me souvenir de ce temps et
je me souviens de ça
Les souffrances que nous avons le plus endurées
que tout alors
Ouais
[Musique]
par rapport à un thermomètre
Le peuple guatémaltèque vit en exil
Perpétuel parce que peut-être perpétuellement
lui a refusé la possibilité de vivre
disons avec sérénité dans notre
alors même ceux qui ne sont pas allés à ça
exilé
au sens strict du terme
Ils ont vécu un exil intérieur Ou bien ils vivent un
exil intérieur nous avons été exilés
Eh bien, du pays des montagnes du
bonheur
de sérénité
d'amour d'une manière claire aussi de
la justice
nous avons été exilés de
égalité et autres valeurs
les utopies dont tu as tant rêvé
les vrais gens, les vautours sont ces oiseaux
donc ils ont été stigmatisés, n'est-ce pas
Les vautours qui mangent des charognes et quelques-uns
comme les vautours nous nettoient un peu
de merde et de chair pourrie et
les viscères
la vérité arrosée par les bombes autour
nous sommes alors devenus un oiseau soudainement
c'est peut-être si sale et si sombre
destiné à remplir une fonction de
brillant dans ce pays
tellement arrosé et tellement baigné d'ordures et
de sang et de chair, pas d'oiseaux
ils expriment d'une certaine manière le désir du ciel
chez l'homme et peut-être l'oiseau
naturel des Guatémaltèques soit-Il
vautour et non El Quetzal comme il l'a fait
destiné à être l'iconographie officielle
nous étions de bons révolutionnaires
l'époque des années soixante-dix et quatre-vingt
jeunes étudiants universitaires et nous rencontrons
Une fois par an, le 20 octobre était le
le jour où ils ont assassiné notre maximum
leader étudiant et nous sommes cinq
survivants
nous avons fait une liste en un an, ils ont assassiné
à 57 nouveaux dirigeants qui n'étaient pas
étudiants ordinaires mais
président des délégués de l'association avant
le conseil supérieur de l'université en bref
si nous n'avions pas réussi à nous échapper
nous aurions
J'ai connu l'exil au temps de Luca
du Brésil, j'ai vécu deux ans et mois
Holland et moi sommes revenus parce que c'est mon
endroit où j'ai vu à quel point les gens étaient précieux
pour le Guatemala, elle n'a été assassinée que par le
écrire ce qu'on a vu
Disons quand je faisais des reportages
sur les enfants des rues ou sur
via les misères seulement, cela signifiait que
C’étaient des communistes, je travaillais à la commission.
de clarification historique après
la signature des accords de paix et
selon les graphiques qui ont été réalisés
Le pire ici s'est produit en 1982, lorsque le
la courbe des morts et des massacres est
jusqu'en haut mais il y a une partie qui
la commission n'a pas réussi à sauver, par exemple
l'an 68 l'horreur politique que
Il vivait dans les zones urbaines à cette époque
surtout de l'intelligentsia
étudiants, c'était horrible, horrible
beaucoup de ces gens de gauche qui
utilisé des armes comme un outil pour
changer la réalité du pays Aujourd'hui, c'est
être un gouvernement avec des génocides avec
des voleurs et des meurtriers alors un
Il dit bien, qu'est-il arrivé à ces rêves ?
qui avait la gauche sur la montagne si
Quand la ville est arrivée, la première chose
il a fait, c'est de conclure un pacte avec ceux qui
Ils ont mis le pied sur le peuple
transition des organisations politiques
guérilla militaire pour faire la fête
hommes politiques d'une transition très difficile
pour la gauche c'est à dire ce nouveau
façon de faire de la politique non plus avec le
fusils et dans les montagnes mais comme
parti politique dans le cadre d'autres règles
du jeu a été une transition
qu'ils n'ont pas pu donner
la crise même de l'idéologie
Marxiste, pas quelle était son idéologie officielle
ne leur a pas permis
se positionner de manière réaliste dans
conditions du monde et du Guatemala en
particulier
[Musique]
Ce sont des expressions s'il vous plaît
musique
nous sommes cool maintenant, ce sont les bons
à l'intérieur et les méchants à l'extérieur
Je suis fermé depuis plus de 15 ans.
la porte de l'entreprise a plus de 35
ans et je le gardais avec
porte ouverte et déjà à 7 heures du soir
il n'y a rien non plus car ça ne vient plus
personnes
Voir que les gens viennent maintenant tôt
ses maisons
Ce sont eux qui n'ont pas de travail, dis-je.
il y a beaucoup de gens sans travail et leurs enfants
Ils veulent aussi manger et c'était tellement bon pour moi
les emplois doivent agresser les gens
tu n'as pas tout vu parce que si tu ne l'as pas vu
J'ai vu j'ai entendu parce que j'ai vu Pas grand chose
parce que je me garde enfermé
tu es depuis deux ans
un étudiant a disparu
psychologue aussi de ma génération
La professeure Mayra Gutiérrez est inconnue
elle et un meurtre est dit
disparition politique Ici et maintenant le
le titre il y a huit jours était Assassiné
le juge d'Izabal un mois avant dit
dirigeant syndical assassiné de la CGTG
dans les rues de la zone un alors je
En particulier, si ma lecture du
la situation politique est qu'il y a un rebond
d'assassinats politiques
lentement, bien sûr, ils ne l'ont pas
Terrible et massif des années
précédent mais ici les choses n'ont pas été
Beaucoup changé
Il y a une phrase qu'il vient de me dire
un ami qui dit l'avoir lu dans un
livre sur le Guatemala où l'épigraphe
le livre commence par ceci, il dit
Le Guatemala est un pays qui n’existe pas.
Je sais pourquoi j'étais là
Mais d'une manière ou d'une autre, cette phrase
paradoxal indique
J'en dirais beaucoup, c'est pour ça que c'est si choquant.
la classe Parce que comme si ce pays n'avait pas
c'est fini, pas comme ça
le pays n'a pas pu
se matérialiser dans les institutions n'a pas
J'ai
s'intégrer plus ou moins dans une identité
général pas commun signifiant ce personnage
de société divisée
confronté
où il n'y a pas de consensus fondamental
sur la façon dont cela devrait être notre
coexistence le grand conflit le grand
l'angoisse est que nous n'appartenons à personne
lieu
c'est les sentir là
Qu'est-ce que je sais mais il n'y a pas une seule nation, c'est une seule
nation imaginaire
inexistant fantastique nous n'existons pas comme
nation pour cette raison contrairement à
des sociétés comme la Colombie, d'autres plus
au-delà de la brutalité de la violence
maintenir et peut maintenir une certaine
identité il y a un imaginaire commun ici
l'imaginaire n'existe pas, il a été brutalisé
il n'y a pas d'écrivains Mayer ou il n'y a rien
[Musique]
souffle-moi ton Simpson
la musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je suis corrompu, ce n'est pas pour cela que je vais être
là je suis corroto c'est ce qu'on dit la maison seule
On accepte, on cherche qui va le faire.
là, nous sommes corrompus pour faire les choses
les maisons et le bureau ici el paladar
organiser les femmes quand il y avait
garderie, commandons
C'est celui qu'ils disaient que nous étions
corruption et argent Quelles institutions avons-nous
Ils donnent de l'argent pour que nous puissions
marre et si tu es au bureau pour le quatrième
pour que c'est là qu'ils vont s'entraîner
les femmes sont dans l'hospitalité
Nous avons demandé deux coins et le
les machines sont venues les tissus et puis
les distributeurs ont été vendus
les tissus et la fuite se sont terminées comme
Ils ont dit que je mangeais le
argent
mais je sens qu'il n'y a pas d'argent, je suis
manger
Ils m'ont mal attrapé parce que donc
ils se cassent la tête, ils me disent
qu'est-ce que je cache
les machines sont arrivées les tissus sont arrivés
la salle à manger est là et le bureau de maman
quel hiver avec ton équipe avec tous tes
fichiers et pire encore, je ne sais pas comment lire comment je vais
envoyer une demande
[Musique]
la construction
souche un
La gamification de la surveillance permet
négocier sa construction
ontona espagnole
[Musique]
vision officielle du Guatemala selon laquelle le soleil
par Miguel
[Musique]